we're on problem 66 and the accompanying
diagram measure of angle a is 32 degrees
and ac is equal to 10 which equation
could be used to find x in triangle abc
so we want x so let's write our
sohcahtoa down so
what have they given us
well x is the opposite side right this
is equal to the opposite it's opposite
of our angle in question
and then this ten side is the adjacent
so i haven't looked at the choices yet
but it see if we say the tangent of 32
degrees
tangent of 32 degrees
should be equal to the opposite side
right opposite side which is x
over the adjacent side which is 10.
and then if we multiply both sides of
this
by 10 we get 10 let me do a darker green
10
tangent
of 32 degrees
is equal to x
and let's hope that's one that's one of
the choices yep sure enough c
x is equal to 10 tangent of 32 degrees
everything in trigonometry really does
boil down to sohcahtoa you'll be amazed
when you actually learn
take trigonometry as a class you'll see
that you know they have all these trig
identities and all of that but all of
those things can be just proved from
sohcahtoa
and these are just definitions of ratios
that have been very useful in the world
when studying triangles
all right 67 but you can watch we have a
whole playlist on trigonometry and we
talk about all the ratios and the unit
circle and all of that so if you if
you're enjoying these problems i
encourage you to watch those videos or
if you don't understand these problems i
encourage you even more to watch those
videos
all right
the diagram shows an eight foot ladder
leaning against the wall the ladder
makes a 53 degree angle with the wall
which is closest to the distance
up the wall the ladder reaches so that's
what this is what they care about this
distance right here
right
so let's see how i would let's see if we
how we can figure it out
if we have right sohcahtoa maybe we
don't have to write that anymore so we
have this angle and what have they given
us they've given us
we want to figure out this deals with
the hypotenuse which is eight and deals
with this adjacent side right so what
deals with the this is the adjacent side
so what trig function deals with the
adjacent side and the hypotenuse well
i'll write it down so
toa
so we have a j we want to figure out
adjacent we have the hypotenuse what
trig function deals with it well cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse right
so the cosine of 53 degrees
the cosine of 53 degrees
is equal to the adjacent side of this
triangle of this right triangle so
that's a
and this we should you should only be
applying these right now with right
triangles later on we'll learn in
trigonometry how the trig functions are
useful for any triangle but anyway going
back to this because obviously only a
right triangle has a hypotenuse so you
know these h's wouldn't be too
meaningful if you're not dealing with a
right triangle but anyway back to the
problem cosine of 53 it equals the
adjacent side over the hypotenuse see
the hypotenuse is 8.
if we multiply oh i can write x there x
is the adjacent side right
so we multiply both sides of this by 8
we get 8 times the cosine of 53
degrees is equal to x
and they tell us let's see they give us
a little chart they tell us that the
cosine of 53 degrees is approximately
equal to 0.6 so this is equal to 0.6 so
we get 8 times 0.6 is equal to x
8 times 0.6 is what 4.8 right it's 48
with one
digit behind the decimal point so x is
equal to 4.8
and that is choice b
problem 68
triangle j k l is shown below
fair enough which equation should be
used to find the length of j k so we
want to find
this is you know this is the this is j
k
all right so we have this angle here
we have this angle here j k is what it's
the opposite side right
we we want to figure out the opposite
side we have the hypotenuse so what trig
function deals with opposite and hop and
the hypotenuse well i could just write
so down i don't have to even write the
whole sohcahtoa because sine is equal to
the opposite side over the hypotenuse so
in this case
sine of 24 degrees
sine of 24
is equal to the opposite side which is
side j k
over the hypotenuse this is the
hypotenuse right here 28 the longest
side of the right triangle or the side
that's opposite the 90 degree angle
and so
maybe we're done because it looks like
that's how they wrote so sine of 24
degrees is equal to jk over 28
and that is
sine
sine of 24 is the oh that's choice a
is equal to the opposite over the
hypotenuse
choice a
problem 69
these are kind of fun aren't they
problem 69 what is the approximate
height in feet of the tree in the figure
below and now you'll see why
trigonometry is useful because i'm sure
you you often wonder how tall is that
tree and
you know it might be hard to climb it
and now you can use trigonometry if you
just have a way to measure the angle
between your line of sight and the and
the and between you know you and the top
of the tree and you know you can kind of
use you've probably seen those um
what do you call them those surveyors
actually they use things like this and
you can figure out the heights of things
far away if you know how far away you
are from it but anyway let's let's let's
work on this problem what is the
approximate height and feet of the tree
in the figure below
okay so this is 50.
so let's think about it
what do they tell us this is 90 this is
50.
so the approximate height in feet so if
okay so this is the opposite side of
this angle right
so let's call this h so what deals with
the
with the opposite side actually i
shouldn't use h because we're let's call
that o o is the height of the tree
because it's opposite the 50 degree
angle right
so what deals with the opposite and the
hypotenuse so once again so katoa right
we just have to look at the so part sine
is equal to opposite over hypotenuse
so the sine of 50 degrees i'll write it
here the sine
of 50 degrees is equal to the opposite
side of this triangle opposite the angle
and that's the height of the tree so
that's i'll say o for height of the tree
over the hypotenuse the hypotenuse is
100 feet
multiply both sides by 100 you get 100
sine
of 50
is equal to this opposite side which is
equal to the height of the tree
sine of 50 is 0.76
so this is 0.76
so 0.76 times 100 is equal to o
well that's 76
is equal to or the height of the tree
and that's choice
oh and they said 0.766 so let's put
another six so that becomes 76.6
and that's choice b
all right
problem 70. these go fast
if a is equal to 3 roots of 3 in the
triangle below so this is equal to three
root three i think you're gonna learn a
little bit about 30 60 90 triangles now
what is the value of b
what is the value of b okay maybe they
assume that you already do know
something about 30-60-90 triangles but
anyway if a is equal to 3 root 3 what is
b and i'm debating on what i should
assume that you already know
but let's think about it a little bit if
i were to
draw let me see if how i can do this
without resorting to just the definition
of 30 60 90 triangles
so if i were to draw so if this angle
and i'll prove it for you although later
you can memorize because when i keep
saying 369 triangles we know that this
right here is 60 degrees
right because 30 plus 60 plus 90 is
equal to 100 degrees so that's why we
keep calling this a 30-60-90 triangle
so how do we figure out this side if we
just know
if we just know
if we just know that side and we know
this is 30 degrees so what i'm going to
do
is i'm going to try to redraw this same
triangle but i'm going to flip it over
and this is actually the proof of
figuring out the measures of 30 60 90
triangle
so maybe i'll do it in a different color
and i have some time so
i'll do it
let's see
so i'll do it like that
then i have to bring another line down
something like that
and then i'll have to draw another line
like well it should actually be more
like that
i could get the idea
and then
bring a line across like that and
actually i'm going to draw another line
down straight down like that
okay let's see what we can do with this
maybe there's an easier way to do it but
this is just what my brain is thinking
of right now
so let's think about a little bit
in this
drawing that i've done
this triangle is just the mirror image
of that one
so this right here
this is also 60
right this is 60 this is 60. what's this
angle going to be well they're all
collectively supplements of each other
right if you go all the way from there
to there you have 180 degrees so this
big angle right here has got to be 60
degrees sorry 60 degrees this angle
right here it's a complement of 30 right
so this is 60 degrees
and then this is 60 degrees
right
so this is an equilateral triangle all
the sides are going to be equal so that
side
is equal to that side
which is equal to this side
right now let me ask another question
what is
what is this side right here
what is let me just draw
a shorter part
and once you memorize 30 60 90 triangles
you don't have to go through all this
but it's good to be able to reprove it
so what's this length right here
well if we look right up there that's
length a
and this was just a mirror image so this
is also length a
right so this whole base of the
equilateral triangle is 2a
well it's an equilateral triangle so all
the sides are the same so this is 2a
and this is 2a and just like that we
were able to figure out the hypotenuse
and they want to know what the b is so
once we know two sides of a right
triangle it's very easy to figure out
the third side so we know that a squared
plus c squared is equal a squared plus b
squared is equal to c squared let me
write that down a squared plus b squared
is equal to c squared
now what's
what's a squared
a squared
let's write a is three roots of three
so a squared would be nine times let me
write it down three roots of three
squared plus b squared is equal to let
me do another color
what's c c we just figured out is two
times a so it's 6 roots of 3
6 roots of 3
squared that's what we did all of this
stuff for to figure out that this length
is twice that length
fair enough now simplify so if you take
3 roots 3 just
the second power the same thing as 3
squared times
square root of 3 squared so that's 9
times 3
plus b squared
is equal to 36
times 3
and so that's 27
plus b squared
is equal to 36 times 3 is 108
108. subtract 27 from both sides b
squared is equal to
let's see 1 is equal to 81.
b is equal to 9. and so that is choice a
anyway you should you should watch the
videos i've done in the trigonometry
playlist on 30 60 90 triangles if you
want to be able to do this faster but i
think that was useful because you've
actually seen how you can how you can
figure out the size of a 369 triangle
without having to memorize it ahead of
time anyway see in the next video